-You know our first guest
tonight from his work
on "Saturday Night Live," wher
he serves as a head writer
as well as co-anchor
of "Weekend Update."
He stars in
"Tom & Jerry: The Movie,"
which premieres in theater
and on HBO Max on Friday.
Please welcome back to the sho
our very good friend Colin Jost.
How are you, buddy?
-Great. How are you?
-Good.
It's so wonderful to see you
I cannot believe --
-I started waving --
When you introduced Raghav
I started waving.
Just I was like,
"Maybe he thinks I'm pretty good
at drumming."
I was like,
"See where this goes."
-Yeah, a lot of people have said
you're a 16-year-old drummer
who's taken the world by storm
-Yeah. I was like,
"Well, I mean, I'll take it.
I know I read as late teens,
but...
-You guys are doing
your fifth show in a row.
I believe your last run
was six shows in a row.
That is a very punishing
schedule.
Obviously, a lot of it
is necessitated
by the times
we're living through,
but are you --
you must be exhausted.
-Yeah, mentally,
I think a lot of us
are hitting a breaking point
But it's very hard --
it's extremely hard to complai
when you work at a comedy show
Be like, "We worked
five weeks in a row!"
You know, to any --
You understand,
but to any sort of, you know
normal functioning human,
they're like, "Uh-huh."
You know,
you can't, like, complain.
With my parents, I'm like,
"Yeah, Mom, you know,
you can't believe I'm workin
five weeks in a row."
And she's like, "Yeah, I worke
just in, like, hospitals
for like six years straigh
without a week off.
So, yeah, no,
that must be tough."
You're like, "Yeah,
okay, that's harder."
-That does make sense, 'caus
I've been trying to get people
to bang pots and pans
at the end of each "SNL"
just to, like, reward you guys
-And it hasn't taken off
in the same way?
-No, nobody wants to engag
that, but I will say --
-I think if you were
thinking of it as booing
and they're booing along, yo
might get some people to join.
Certain weeks, you might
get some people to join in
-Some people said
they would like
to come out on their balconies
and just scream how
it was better in the '70s.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, that's right.
They didn't do enough
with the host.
Cast is great.
Writers are terrible.
They just yell that.
-But, I mean,
a very real cost of this -
and obviously, again,
this is the right choice
based on safety --
but, you know, whether the "SNL"
was good or bad,
the nicest part of the way
the week was structured
is at the end of the show,
you went out with everybody.
And it could either
lift your mood
or, if your mood was great
it would elevate it.
So how weird is it
when the shows are over
that everybody
just kind of dissipates?
-It's very strange.
I mean, the first part is,
there's no energy backstage.
So when you get off, if yo
felt like things went grea
or you felt they went horribly
either way, there's nothing.
You walk into, like,
a wall of silence.
Normally, you'd see,
you know, whatever.
Adam Levine's there, and he'
like, "Hey, what's up, man
Good job."
Or, you know, there's a llam
and Abraham Lincoln
from the costume before.
And, you know,
the Abraham Lincoln's,
like, got a couple notes
for you --
"Maybe hold your head this way,"
or whatever, you know,
things like that.
You're getting energy.
And this is --
You have no --
You have nothing.
And then there's no --
Normally, you would
sort of decompress
with your friends
after the show,
you know, like, your fello
castmates, the writers.
You'd talk about
how things went.
And then you're operating
in this weird vacuum
and you have none of the release
and none of the social par
of the show.
And there's no -- It must be
so weird to start this year,
like, new people that started,
because there's no, like,
going out for a drink
after the table read
and learning about why thing
aren't getting in the show
or not getting in the show
Everyone's living
in their own weird vacuum.
And when you see people
with masks on,
you never want to talk
to anyone with a mask on.
You're just like,
"Yeah, alright, whatever."
It feels like you're greetin
someone in a hospital.
-It's so true about new people
because I remember
when I started,
one of my first reactions was,
"Huh, so there's no cocain
anymore."
And now for them, it must be
"So there's not even beer!
-Yeah, you're allowed
one soft drink after the show.
But you really do.
Like, truly, like,
we'll have a drink --
We'll have, like,
one beer in a hallway
where you're shouting down the
hallway to a fellow cast member.
And that's, like, the closes
we've had to a party.
-Sounds great.
-So this is the year
to sign up, guys!
If you're looking to join,
sign up.
I'm really selling it.
And it's a dream job.
Everyone's on the verge
of a mental breakdown,
and you can't drink anymor
at work.
Sorry.
-We did --
You know, we obviously --
To be in the building, you know,
you and I get tested every day
And we took advantage of that.
I'm happy to say
that two weeks ago,
after my show,
I just hung out in my office
and then you came down
to my office,
and we got super hammered an
watched YouTube videos together.
-Yeah, it was pretty fun.
You ordered us cheeseburgers
And we ate cheeseburgers o
your desk like it was a table.
-Yep.
-Great. One of the greates
nights out of my life.
-Yeah.
That's the new Rainbow Room.
-Oh, yeah.
-The new Rainbow Room
is office burgers and YouTube.
And then we both --
At the end of the night,
we both spun around
and we went, "New York City!
-I mean, that was probably
my wildest night out in New York
in the last six months.
-100%.
-And I didn't leave
the building.
-Yeah.
You did --
Since the last time you were
on the show -- obviously,
as established, I've seen you --
you did get married.
"Jost married."
And this is --
For people who couldn't tell
by Colin's gold chain,
he is from Staten Island.
[ Both laugh ]
-That's where we did the wedding
and the reception.
Cans are real.
My brother did
some great Photoshop work.
I know it looks real,
but they didn't actually tie
a bunch of 100-foot-long can
on the back of
the Staten Island Ferry.
I mean, they probably -- Someone
would have used it as an excus
to get bodies in the can
that they needed to get rid of
Someone I grew up with would
have put bodies in the can
and been like, "Oh."
Yeah, it's also very strange
to get married,
because part of marriage is,
obviously,
sort of entering society
as a couple, you know.
That's, like, the traditiona
idea of marriage.
So instead, it's like,
just, again,
everything happening
in a vacuum,
and some of our closest friend
we haven't seen in a year,
you know, couldn't come
to the wedding.
And we actually went through -
We got engaged and then
immediately went to London
to film -- I went to film
"Tom & Jerry,"
and Scarlett went to film
"Black Widow."
We'll see which one ends u
being the bigger hit.
[ Both laugh ]
The jury's out!
-Colin, Colin,
do not put money on this.
-[ Laughs ]
-We left -- We got engaged
then basically fled town,
so I didn't see anyone
that summer.
Then I went right back int
"SNL," and then COVID hit.
So there's been basically
these two years
that have been a huge moment
in our lives
where we haven't seen
most of our friends.
-Wait, am I finding out no
for the first time
that Tom and Jerry
are also British actors
who were doing American accent
this whole time?
-Yes.
That's the big scoop.
Yeah.
We just had Regé on,
and hopefully we'll see,
fingers crossed, Tom and Jerry
join Nick Jonas this week.